sharks the most feared animals on the
planet
despite inspiring such Terror
the chances of being bitten are
incredibly rare
but what about being bitten twice
unlucky victims survived not just one
but two shark attacks
[Music]
I grew up in Florence Oregon I was born
up there on the banks of this Isla River
Seth Mead is a watershed conservationist
from the Oregon coast
he serves every chance he gets you know
I froth for it there are days when I I
can't you know think about anything else
and this passion means Seth is in the
right place
the Oregon coast boasts some of the most
awe-inspiring waves on the planet
strong winds create swells that can
reach more than 35 feet high and travel
up to 65 miles per hour
drawing Surfers to the water in droves
but these Thrill Seekers aren't out
there alone
on the west coast of the United States
this area has to be one of the sharkiest
places
Oregon's waters are home to 15 species
of shark
s commonly found off the coast of Oregon
include white sharks blue sharks salmon
sharks thresher sharks and spiny Dogfish
unlike the majority of sharks that are
cold-blooded many of these species are
warm-blooded
that means they can raise their body
temperature above that of the
surrounding water
it's them warm
Oregon's frigid Waters where
temperatures average around 55 degrees
in the summer but wetsuit wearing
Surfers don't mind the cold either
[Music]
I didn't really worry too much about
actually getting bit by a shark
I assumed they were there but I wasn't
necessarily worried about
bad occurring
The Jetty there I was sitting a couple
hundred yards south of it on that wide
Peak down there
pretty similar weather conditions to
today the little weather cell that had
just came through had just passed you
know Sunny clear it was sick
but the good times don't last long
so I was sitting you know upright
looking out of the Horizon and
all of a sudden you know bam
she hit me so hard that we projected out
of the water
when Seth lands the unthinkable occurs I
was in essence balancing on my board
which was spanning her mouth
and her mouth was probably something
about like that and I was on the board
like looking down into it the shark
bites down hard
trapping Seth's right foot between his
surfboard and the shark's teeth
I felt compression
is her lower jaw my foot my board then
her top job
and then I heard my board snap
[Music]
and then she spun around
and just let go
but the shark doesn't swim away
so Seth does kind of glance over my
shoulder at her glance at the horizon
and I've paddled for my life
[Music]
ran up the beach
remember my wetsuit was twisted around
and I couldn't see the actual wounds
there was just a bunch of really dark
blood
a nearby police officer helped Seth to
the emergency room
where he receives 25 stitches across
multiple lacerations
could have been a lot worse surprise it
wasn't worse
I think if the board hadn't been
sandwiched in there
there's a high probability I could have
lost my foot so yeah I feel very
fortunate the way things turned out
Seth's terrifying shark encounter stuns
locals this is a total surprise to me at
the time
there have been numerous sightings but I
was unaware of any previous shark
attacks in this area
I think everybody was surprised
basically lived out here you know that
was the first time any of us had
witnessed anything like that
historically incidents off of Gold Beach
Oregon between humans and sharks are
extremely rare most years in Oregon they
see between zero and three attacks since
1974 along Oregon's entire Coastline
only 29 shark bites have been reported
and Gold Beach where Seth was attacked
has only been the site of one other
incident ever so why did a shark strike
Seth and why now
the local community definitely wonders
investigators begin to unravel the
mystery
Dr Mark marks studies the behavioral
Ecology of sharks
he believes figuring out which species
bit Seth may help explain why it
occurred
he turns to a crucial piece of evidence
Seth's surfboard
didn't hear what looks like stress
fractures the board made a very distinct
pop when the bite occurred I'm guessing
the crack is probably a simultaneous
stress fracturing here and then the
teeth actually puncturing through the
glass
one of the things that's really
diagnostic is the shape like human
fingerprints each species of sharks has
its own distinct teeth marks those of
the tiger shark are large and serrated
designed to rip and tear into prey
whereas those of the basking shark are
microscopic and virtually useless
swallowing prey rather than chewing
now the shark that made this bite you
see how these guys are triangular yeah
the flat side
from the Apex that's going to be the
front of the tooth you get these
straight blade cut here so it's the
bottom tooth which made these according
to Dr Marx there's only one species
whose teeth fit this bill so if we tried
to line this up what you'll see are
probably these two teeth here lines up
at that edge it's it's almost a perfect
fit this is a white shark
white sharks are the largest predatory
fish on the planet
growing up to 20 feet in length they are
highly intelligent incredibly powerful
and they're responsible for more attacks
on humans than any other fish in the sea
the chances of being bit
shark
or any other are incredibly Slim
Dr Dan Huber of the University of Tampa
breaks it down the odds of being bitten
by a shark are incredibly low if we look
around the entire world it's about 1 in
79 million if we bring that into the
United States the odds are more like
about one in eight million but not
everybody in the United States goes to
the beach so if we look specifically at
the odds of being attacked by a shark
amongst beachgoers in the United States
the odds are about one in three million
by comparison
the odds of dying from a lightning
strike
a roughly one in eighty thousand
according to Dr Huber's stats you are
100 times more likely to be struck by
lightning than attacked by a shark
or almost 1 000 times more likely
worldwide
and those are the odds for getting
attacked once
so you might wonder what are the odds of
being bitten twice by a shark as a peach
grower in the United States in order to
figure out the probability of two
separate events happening twice we need
to multiply their individual
probabilities so if we multiply one out
of three million by one out of three
million we get one in nine trillion and
I don't know about you but that's about
the lowest odds of anything I've ever
heard of in my life so the fact that
anybody in the United States has been
bitten by a shark twice
is just extraordinarily low odds
but unlikely does not mean impossible
and somehow Seth defies the odds after
my first shark attack I figured the
percentages of it happening again it was
so slim that I was golden now I figured
I'd paid my dues if it was gonna happen
it was going to be somebody else little
does Seth know how wrong he is
six years after Seth's shark attack he
goes surfing with his best friend Gus
they head to an Oregon beach located
more than 100 miles north of Seth's
shark incident
but Seth's traumatic past isn't behind
him
yet
so you're out off like
essentially right out in there
it had been raining for a couple days
so we took the rip out
and was sitting there it was a nice calm
kind of tranquil looking and
then
you'd hear that sound sounded like
sandpaper
and then bam a shark slams into Seth
throwing him off his surfboard
next thing I really knew I'm in the
water
look over and saw my board in the
shark's mouth
and I'm Tethered to it so I'm within
feet of the entire animal unable to flee
Seth is at the shark's Mercy
is he gonna follow up with a secondary
hit
or is he just gonna let me sneak out of
here
the second's tip by and at some point I
let go of my board
and I remember getting on my board
looking out and seeing Gus
it was just a moment of panic just kind
of froze it was like what the heck did I
just see
we were just laser focused on getting
back to the beach not really looking
over our shoulders
I've never paddled so fast in my life
Seth and Gus Escape unscathed
I don't know how that he didn't actually
get me he just got my board because
there's a pretty significant gouge on
the bottom of the board
and then the upper jaw definitely was on
the side of the board
I was like man this is I think your
lucky day you probably should go buy a
lottery ticket or something
chances of winning the lottery may be
higher than what he just survived
for Seth to encounter a shark twice in
Oregon Waters in separate years and be
the only person to do so is unbelievably
rare
this unprecedented second attack
puts locals on high alert I was in total
disbelief it was just you know kind of
unheard of at the time
now more than ever the mystery Behind
These encounters must be solved why was
Seth bitten not once but twice
in search of a lead investigators look
for similarities between the two
incidents
starting with the identity of Seth's
attacker
we've got what looks to be a two-jaw
bite
I think I know which teeth did these if
we turn it over we're going to see some
corresponding lower jaw which we do
but I think we're looking at an animal
that's probably in around the 14
-foot range I'm about 99.5 confidence
level we have a white shark that hit you
two attacks both by great whites
with the culprit's identity revealed
experts can now Focus their
investigation
why would a white shark attack Dr Mark
searches for clues in the local
environment and something stands out
here on the West Coast we have a lot of
henna pads Pena pads are marine sea
mammals including seals and sea lions
pinnipeds are one of the most commonly
seen marine animals in Oregon
numbering in the tens of thousands year
round
they also happen to be on a great whites
menu
white sharks learn how to head them off
at the pass or how to stalk them or
Ambush them
a great white is equipped with both
brains and Brawn giving it an uncanny
ability to hunt pinnipeds
they're intelligent they learn they
adapt they have modified their hunting
techniques these are very sharp
predators in its most spectacular
display the Predator sneaks up on his
prey and attacks From Below at speeds of
up to 40 miles per hour
but this remarkable hunting technique
isn't foolproof
any carnivore has to be successful at
least 10 percent of the time or it won't
survive I can tell you most definitely
sharks are way above that 10 percent
threshold
that means sometimes great whites miss
their target or attack the wrong target
altogether
I do think the shark thought I was a sea
lion I think she was prowling the lineup
and I was in a likely Zone
mistaken identity did a great white
attempt to inflict a mortal wound on
Seth confusing him for a pinup head I've
been told that's one of their kind of
quintessential attack modes is to come
in get a good hit sit back and let you
bleed out
that's probably what she was doing
to test this Theory Dr Marx recreates
Seth's first attack now
from the injuries the scars what I see
is that your foot is back
these lower teeth puncture the bottom
these teeth here catch the bottom of
your foot so that thing's head was up
here pretty much yeah I mean I remember
looking right into her
and then as things transpired and she
started to kind of roll back
we determined she does like a lateral
roll just like that and then now you're
looking at her eye here does it passed
right through there that's where we kind
of locked eyes
the positioning and force of the shark
suggests it may have been hunting
but Dr Marx has his reservations sure
it's a pretty intelligent animals by the
time a white shark becomes an adult it's
unlikely they make mistakes we can look
at the injuries and evidence from Seth
for example in both of his encounters
neither of them look like predation and
the reason they don't look like
predation is because they are not
perhaps the answer to Seth's
odds-defying double encounter can be
found in another freak occurrence
elsewhere one that took place in the
SharkBite capital of the world
East Marina Beach is a small town
there's tons of surfing swimming fishing
it's just a water-based Town Matt Glenn
is a surfer from New Smyrna Beach in
Florida yeah we love everything about it
located along Florida's eastern coast
it's home to dolphins
manatees alligators and sharks but
unlike the rest of the country where
shark attacks are rare here they are
more common earning the area a chilling
claim to fame
we are the SharkBite capital of the
world we do have more shark bites than
anywhere else on the east coast in fact
since 1882 this area has seen a shocking
total of more than 330 shark attacks we
usually average about six to ten shark
bites a year we had our record year in
2001 where he had 21 bites in one year
despite the danger from Matt the call of
the ocean is too strong to ignore I
still love surfing I'll go every day if
I could it's just a feeling that you
really can't be so people take that
chance you know
around 9 A.M Matt and his friend Brian
hit the water
that day the weather it was the day
after a hurricane rolled through so it
was real Breezy but there was tons of
sun it was just you know a beautiful
Florida day
they're catching some really good waves
as well was amazing
after half an hour Matt notices
something is off
all of a sudden our tight little group
we were missing our buddy Brian and
um
we just started looking around but as
Matt looks he hears something chilling
we heard Brian scream help me shark
and then our instincts just took over
Matt races to reach his friend while
Brian fights against the Predator
that shark was on him attached to his
leg and we saw him kind of
struggle
somehow Brian breaks free
scrambling onto his surfboard he races
to safety as soon as we saw Brian make
it into the shore
we were all there to help him he had the
shark laceration like right around his
kneecap area and one of our buddies
quickly took off his leash we wrapped
around his upper thigh to kind of make a
tourniquet
and basically all we could do is just
sit there and wait for the Lifeguard to
come
it's an excruciating weight the blood
was basically just oozing out of his
knee
Ryan receives emergency medical
attention
and makes a full recovery
I'm grateful that I didn't have it any
worse than was no stitches no nothing
and
it's a blessing
Brian's terrifying encounter leaves
locals rattled
other Surfers were attacked just one
week before
even in the shark attack capital of the
world three attacks in seven days is
unusual it was it was it was insane yeah
pretty wild if an answer can't be found
the livelihood of this vacation hot spot
is at risk we are often asked by
tourists that come from all over the
country if there are sharks in the water
when we have a shark right here that
becomes a problem
especially Out of Towners
so why was Brian bitten
to identify Brian's attacker Dr Huber
examines the evidence
based on the size of the wound going
from about the middle of Brian's knee to
the middle of his shin I'm estimating
that this was something on the order of
a five to six foot black tip shark
black tip sharks are known for their
characteristic black fins
their preferred hunting ground is in the
shallows
where they sometimes encounter humans
black tip sharks worldwide are only
responsible for about five percent of
shark attacks but because they're so
common off the coast of Florida they
definitely contribute to a greater
percentage of Florida shark attacks
[Music]
why did Brian attract The Unwanted
attention of a black tip
Beach safety officer Captain Tamara
malfers has a theory Surfers will go out
regardless of any storm system that
comes through that's what they do
Brian Was Bitten in the direct aftermath
of Hurricane Matthew
right after that hurricane I think it
was just a matter of who was going to
get bit that day
similarly in Oregon Seth's first attack
took place in the wake of a thunderstorm
could these weather patterns have played
a part in the incidents
ocean scientist Dr Tracy fanara
investigates
storms play a big role in the ecosystem
by creating waves big waves which are
ideal for surfing offshore winds create
the best waves
big waves after a storm
are the reason both Seth and Brian were
in the water when attacked but these
storms affect more than what's happening
above the surface
Dr fanara demonstrates
so I'm going to put some cold water with
red food dye on the bottom to symbolize
the nutrients on the bottom of the ocean
now I'm going to use the leaf blower to
show the water displacement
as you can see even though we only put
the air and simulated the surface waves
that bottom water displaced the top
water turning the entire tank red
through a process called upwelling big
waves caused by large storms displace
water and other sediment the problem is
that this upwelling can turn clear water
into murky water
this impedes a shark's ability to see
the water was very murky so that
murkiness would have made it harder for
the shark to see their normal prey items
which may have led the Sharks to bite
onto a Human Instead of their typical
prey
blurry vision for a shark May spell
disaster for a surfer a detail that
could unravel the mystery once and for
all
did the storms that preceded Brian's and
Seth's attacks create murky water and
put the Surfers at a greater risk of a
shark attack
according to Dr Dan Huber
the answer may go beyond water clarity
Seth Was Bitten in deep water roughly
400 feet from Shore
[Music]
and as it turns out that may be exactly
where sharks were gathering
years ago there was a really interesting
observation about shark behavior before
these types of storm events
it turns out that when storm systems
come through and the air pressure drops
significantly
that some sharks can actually detect
this and move offshore into deeper safer
water
so given that both Brian and Seth went
surfing shortly after the storm
it was actually likely for there to be
sharks there and increasing those odds
than being attacked even further
but Seth's second encounter did not
occur in the wake of a storm
waves caused by weather systems are not
the reason behind Seth and Brian's
attacks
investigators wonder if waves are
important in a different way
only eight months after Brian's shark
incident he's back on his surfboard at a
beach less than five miles from his
attack site
the surfer's second shock encounter
holds a clue
we're here at Ponce Inlet
Ray passes pulls about 40 to 50 yards is
where I got my second shark bite
came over to Ponce Inland Beach
it's about eight o'clock in the morning
the water was
a lot of bait fish
which is pot of wave
and did a maneuver then landed fell
but as Brian attempts to regain his
footing disaster strikes
boom like I just felt the pit
I immediately thought it was another
shark bite and this assailant is even
more aggressive than the first and the
full jaw going back and forth sideways
with my foot and shook it
I was screaming
it was just insane
in the chaos of the attack Brian's hand
was also bitten
finally the shark let's go
there was a surfer right there that
helped me to shore
and I was seeing all the blood just
trailing behind me
this is the most I've ever bled in my
entire life
that was pretty terrified
Ryan is rushed to the hospital
where he receives 48 Stitches the second
bite was definitely more serious than
the first bite
I was scared that I could have lost
these two toes and got nerve damage
going from here all the way to here for
Brian this fear is all too familiar I'm
unlucky that I've been bit twice but
very lucky to still be alive to this day
headlines startling the world
here in Bush County the New Smyrna area
we've heard of people get bit there a
lot but I've never heard of one person
getting bit twice
and beachgoers want to know what's going
on
in Brian's first attack he had
relatively minor surface wounds but in
his second attack it actually took 48
stitches in order to close up this wound
and the reason for that is because a
shark bit and then shook its head back
and forth from left to right and the
curvature that we see right here from
the side of the foot up towards the
middle toe would tend to indicate a
black tip or a spinner shark
both of Brian's attacks were conducted
by a black tip or spinner
and both of Seth's attacks were carried
out by great whites
different species different coasts yet
all of these attacks share a similar
detail
I would say New Smyrna Beach Inlet Jetty
it's just a wave magnet
Gus who is piling out the rip you know
about the tip of the jetty
Jetties
Seth believes this common trait between
the attack sites is key the major river
mounts they're all Sharky everything's
getting funneled right through the
gauntlet it's pretty logical for the top
of the food chain to be lumen
could River mouths be the clue
investigators have been looking for
Dr Huber pursues the lead all four of
these attacks happen near the mouths of
rivers
and this is what creates really good
surfing brakes
but Surfers aren't the only ones drawn
to River mouths
the mouths of rivers are definitely
areas where sharks are typically found
the reason for this is because lots and
lots of nutrients come down rivers and
then spill into the ocean
phytoplankton are going to use all of
those nutrients in order to grow and bit
by bit it works its way up the food
chain to bring in larger predators
anytime there is an influx of sharks in
an area the chance of encounters with
humans also increases
the fact that Seth and Brian were
surfing in areas where Rivers were
pouring into the ocean is definitely an
explanatory factor into why they were
attacked twice
but it might not be that simple a detail
from Brian's second shark encounter
complicates the theory in the moment
when I was getting bit it just amazed me
that it happened to me and no one else
in the water nearly a dozen other
Surfers were nearby when Brian was
attacked
yet the shark left them alone
surfing near river mouths cannot be the
only explanation
let's
but what this Theory does show is that
sharks are attracted to areas with an
abundance of fish
and there's one event that brings
fishier in the millions we have seen
them actually a lot of them coming in
and you do see the larger sharks coming
in as well
this is the mullet migration it's an
awe-inspiring phenomenon of epic
proportions and it just might explain
the attacks
each year schools of fish larger than a
football field travel South along the
Atlantic coast to spawn
passing Florida's beaches along their
way
and they do so in the fall
Brian was attacked in October
the water was just a lot of bait fish
I was paddling back out and I was
running my hands through mullet and I
didn't really think much of it
but this migration doesn't just bring
mullet to New Smyrna
ever you have Muller running or any
other
to the larger sharks coming in as well
it's a sequence of events that's not
unique to just Florida
you can see the bait balls see the
Chinook rally and chasing the bait right
under you the second you get in the
water you know you're entering the food
chain
in Oregon
Salmon Run almost year round and just
like the mullet they leap out of the
water to avoid being prey
we have large migrations of salmon
they're reliable food source and of
course with that goes the predator of
those fish such as marine mammals and
that brings sharks
mullet in Florida salmon in Oregon did
these floating buffets attract sharks in
large numbers and put Brian and Seth at
greater risk of an attack
it all comes down to timing both of
Seth's attacks happen during salmon runs
off the coast of Oregon and one of
Brian's attacks happened during a mullet
run off the coast of Florida
so in three out of four of these attacks
the concentration of small fish in the
area of these Surfers could have been a
factor that contributed to why they were
attacked
however there were no fish migrations
during Brian's second incident
something else may be the cause of the
attacks perhaps the answer to these rare
double attacks lies not in the behavior
of the sharks
but in that of the Surfers
investigators review the data and zero
in on a seemingly minor detail
the surfer's clothing that day I was
wearing is the black wetsuit with a hood
pretty usual for around these parts we
get some pretty cold Waters at times so
you need a real suit to keep yourself
warm during both incidents I was wearing
the same board shorts like I was wearing
Blackboard shorts both men wore dark
clothes when bitten could there be a
connection
Dr Hubert takes a closer look
shark eyes are evolved to see high
contrast images such as the silhouette
of a seal at the surface of the water
against the downwelling sunlight so for
a surfer to be in a dark wetsuit on a
surfboard this creates the same type of
search image that sharks depend on to
find their food
this could lead to a shark
to make a mistake while hunting
most sharks don't have color vision or
maybe have very limited color vision and
so because of that they're going to see
objects in the environment differently
than we do
take the example of Seth's attacks off
the coast of Oregon he was attacked by a
white shark both times now white sharks
have black and white vision and they use
high contrast images in order to key in
on the location of their prey like seals
and sea lions
so when a white shark is swimming down
in the depths of the ocean looking up at
the surface what it sees is the prey
item's body silhouetted against the
downwelling sunlight
we're going to try to demonstrate this
effect by taking these objects made to
look like surfboards in a variety of
different colors and we're going to see
what these objects look like from the
shark's perspective Dr Huber places a
small camera on the bottom of a fish
tank to compare color vision versus
black and white or shark vision we're
going to start with the black surfboard
because Seth was wearing a black wetsuit
during both of his attacks off the coast
of Oregon and Brian was wearing a black
bathing suit during both of his attacks
off the coast of Florida
take a look at it in color it is high
contrast compared to all of the light
that's coming down from above which is
meant to simulate the light from the sun
coming down through the surface of the
ocean when we switch that over to black
and white it's still very very high
contrast so this speaks to how the white
shark was able to see Seth in each of
his attacks when the white shark is
swimming around through the depths of
the ocean looking up at the surface any
black object whether it be a seal a sea
lion or a surfer in a black wetsuit
that's going to be a high contrast image
that really stands out against the
downwelling sunlight and it's something
that the shark is going to be able to
key in on
when we switch to the red surfboard in
color it stands out clear as day but
interestingly when we switch over to
black and white to simulate the shark's
Vision it actually becomes very low
contrast
that means it's much harder for a shark
to see so these black objects whether it
be the wetsuit or the bathing suit have
the highest contrast relative to the
surrounding water and sunlight and this
is exactly how shark Vision Works shark
vision is based on identifying high
contrast objects not identifying color
objects
did Seth and Brian's high contrast
attire inadvertently draw a shark's eye
and cause the attacks
[Music]
what Seth and Brian were wearing could
definitely be contributing factors to
the reasons why they were attacked twice
but many beachgoers wear black and are
not attacked
what makes Brian and Seth different
perhaps it's not about what they were
wearing but what they were doing
investigators are on the brink of
answers
after the first attack the probability
of me and popped again very low I
definitely didn't think it would happen
again
so if we look specifically at the odds
of being attacked by a shark amongst
beachgoers in the United States the odds
are about one in three million so to put
that in perspective think about a royal
flush a royal flush is the hardest hand
to get in a game of poker and the odds
of doing that are about 1 in 650 000. so
the odds of being bitten by a shark as a
beach goer in the United States
are about five times lower than the odds
of getting the rarest hand in the game
of poker
way of Louisiana State University
studies the way in which a beach goer's
Pastime can impact their odds of being
bitten
so most shark attacks have some type of
activity associated with the attack for
example surfing swimming or diving
the purple is the unknown the blue is
the swimming
but one activity eclipses all the rest
[Music]
what stands out here is surfing in green
around 50 percent on average and we see
especially starting around the 1980s or
so if we look at the known activities
surfing tends to be in most years the
dominant activity associated with shark
attacks
surfing
Brian and Seth's favorite activity
who spends the most time in the water
well Surfers could be sitting on top for
hours divers an hour maybe less swimmers
less than that so the statistical
probability of you encountering a shark
much less encountering more than once is
really a function of how much you sit at
this place your chances of being struck
by lightning pretty nil but if you were
a chimney sweep around lightning rods
you would expect to see the frequency of
lightning strike higher but there are
approximately 3 million Surfers in the
United States and of those only 15 are
attacked by sharks on average each year
in a case like Brian who was serving in
Florida we wouldn't expect him to be
attacked but we would expect a higher
chance of encountering a shark because
you've had hundreds of encounters and
attacks over a 60-year period that also
suggests that Seth's case is much much
more unlikely because there have been
only 22 attacks in that same 60-year
period in Oregon and in fact Seth
accounts for two of those 22.
foreign
and Seth that sets them apart
even from other Surfers i surf every
chance I can get
and honestly nothing will stop me from
surfing yeah I have about 200 to 220
sessions in a year
[Music]
above what they do the primary factor
of why I been bitten twice
just because I love surfing I'm out
there doing it so often
an extreme love of surfing
could this be the final piece of the
puzzle in explaining these rare double
attacks
in Brian's second attack he was surfing
on a day when there were a lot of bait
fish around the beach and he reported
actually having seen sharks in the area
so the fact that somebody would be
willing to continue surfing when they've
seen sharks feeding on Bait fish really
speaks to how much this person loves to
be in the water surfing
being at one with the ocean feeling how
small you are in the grand scope of
things
it's an intimidating but exhilarating
experience you know there's nothing
that's really comparable
I can go days on end without seeing the
land basically that's how I feel about
it
the risk just
just the enjoyment of surfing
the only way that a person could
possibly put themselves into a situation
to be attacked by sharks on two
different occasions if they are so in
love with the ocean that they are doing
everything that they can to spend as
much time possible in that environment
despite the increased risk Brian and
Seth hope to never stop surfing
you can't compare it to anything else
there are days when I I can't you know
think about anything else
I never planned to retire from surfing
this is something that is a lifelong
endless Journey
[Music]